what a crazy weekend just unbelievable
at the top of the list of news over the
weekend Donald Trump's executive order a
temporary ban of immigrants from seven
muslim-majority countries from entering
the United States for the next 90 days
this has been called the protecting the
nation from foreign terrorists entry
into the United States doesn't really
roll off the tongue doesn't really
matter because what matters is what it
does a senior White House official said
that this is just a first step towards a
broader permanent band that Donald Trump
would like the seven countries on the
list Iraq Syria Iran Libya Somalia Sudan
and Yemen very interesting not only the
countries on the list but the country is
not on the list and we'll get to that a
little bit later this was the same list
of countries named in a 2016 law
concerning immigration visas as
countries of concern under President
Obama many false equivalencies from
Trump ian saying obama did the same
thing incorrect completely different
circumstances and this also suspends the
admission of refugees for four months a
reduced number of refugees who could
eventually be admitted into the u.s.
depending on how this goes is now at
50,000 compared to 110,000 per year
under President Obama here's the
question if you are a devoted trumpet
who think this is the greatest thing
since sliced bread are you happy with
eventually setting a cap at 50,000 I
mean if one terrorist can wreak havoc
and ten can pull off truly massive
attacks are you satisfied if your
glorious orange leader reduces the
number from 110,000 to 50,000 I don't
know that's a question that we will
ultimately get to also Syrian refugees
band period by this executive order some
people still think that the ban is only
on refugees it is on all nationals from
these countries seeking to come to the
United States and there's four ways are
really three ways to look at this number
one is it legal including
constitutionality number two is it
corrupt or self-serving
to president Trump and this is very
important in the Trump era and number
three is this going to achieve the
supposed goal of keeping America safe
those are the three areas I want to dig
into and we'll start with the is it in
line with American law and values
constitutionality etc before I get into
the detail right the current vice
president is on record as having said
that this is unconstitutional he's not a
legal expert but just to remind you of
Mike Pence's opinion about this remember
when he tweeted in December of 2015
calls to ban Muslims from entering the
US are offensive and unconstitutional
let's get into the constitutionality
this is indeed a violation of the First
Amendment's Establishment Clause it
prohibits the government from favoring
one religion over another now you might
hear this as a devoted Trump Ian and say
but David this is based on country of
origin not religion but Trump sort of
screws himself here because the order
directs the Secretary of State quote in
consultation with the Secretary of
Homeland Security to after this
temporary period make changes to the
extent permitted by law to prioritize
refugee claims made by individuals on
the basis of religious based persecution
provided that they are members of a
minority religion in the individual's
country of nationality meaning that
eventually Trump has already said i will
start allowing religiously religious
persecution based refugees as long as
they're not the majority religion in the
country's meaning as long as they are
not muslims and it's very transparent
what this is all about and i don't think
he's fooling anyone because he said on
the campaign trail that he wanted to
issue a temporary ban on Muslims
entering the United States and then he
went to rudy giuliani and said how do we
make this done legally right and then of
course it seems like he's going to give
preference to christian refugees
entering the United States oh the effect
of this even if it is not in a literal
sense a Muslim ban is a particularly on
would be Muslim immigrant it's not just
the First Amendment that this violates
the Fifth Amendment's Due Process Clause
also contains an Equal Protection
component which bars discrimination on
the basis of religion that
just bolsters the Establishment Clause
claim and now you might hear me say all
of that stuff and say David you know
what constitutional law is really up to
interpretation courts would have to see
it through you would have to get a
challenge with standing and it might be
a long time until we know the
constitutionality throw away the
Constitution into the trash which I know
Republicans usually don't want to do but
maybe now they do we've had laws like
this immigration ban at different
moments in history in the late 1800s
starting with Chinese immigrants almost
all Japanese were at one point
effectively banned then all Asians in
what was called the Asiatic a bard zone
in 1924 Congress passed a national
origin system all of this type of thing
was banned in 1965 by the Immigration
and Nationality Act which said no
discrimination against immigrants on the
basis of national origin so if you don't
believe this is about religion we have
law from 1965 that says you can't
discriminate in terms of immigrants on
the basis of national origin now Trump
has been asked about this pad and he
said well there is this 1952 law that
allows the President to suspend the
entry of any class of aliens that he
finds her detrimental to the interest of
the US what he forgets his that based on
our understanding of time time moves
forward and 1965 came after 52 and made
the 52 rule irrelevant yeah i think the
other unfortunate thing here too is that
it's a 90-day band so by the time the
courts really it gets to examining this
could be up by that it could be up it
could have been there could be another
one that has slightly different language
who knows what's going to go on and by
the way you can recognize to preempt the
the you know you know who you can
recognize that radical Islamic terrorism
around the world is a problem but still
realize that this policy is illegal
unconstitutional not useful you can also
recognize that many of these countries
ban Israeli citizens entry to the
country outright which is absurd and
exactly what I'm criticizing here and
I'm critical of that as well but you can
still think that this policy is illegal
unconstitutional and counterproductive